what's going on reject nation we're
about to show you our trailer reaction
for jackass forever
my father figures as a child try getting
this up a little bit earlier but the
copyright clay yeah claims yeah
you know in a perfect world they
wouldn't claim us at all very true john
they're in need of a revolution we could
use a video sponsor on this one
hey john yeah what are you playing on
your phone what am i playing on my phone
with just one hand if you want to be
that
specific i'm playing perfect world
revolution
you can move characters release skills
and bakerish demons
all with a single hand that's right man
tell me more well then perfect world
revolution is an immersive
easy to play vertical mmorpg and
in portrait mode you can play one-handed
really yeah i feel like if there's
anything i've communicated about the
game
so you can play with one hand tell me
more
you can play and chat with friends and
foes across the globe
with only one hand language barrier
schmangage barrier
explore vistas of land air and sea
brought to life in beautiful realistic
light
with only one hand customized characters
across three different races and seven
mighty classes
with only one hand what do i have to do
just download the game available now to
do it now got it cool
this is why we were really late to the
reaction
who
will meet again i don't know where
don't know when guys this show movies
were such a big part of my life
so much youth with the jackass crew oh
[Applause]
well it'll get more mature
the faster you pedal your bike the
faster the other guy's hand goes back
oh machine gun kelly
concussions aren't great but as long as
you have them before you're 50
it's cool and knoxville is 49 so we're
good
oh my god knock you're too old knock
straight always on the toilet
wow
that's a great shot always getting hit
in the nuts
we have winners and we have steve
a bunch of nasa
you still got those million dollar teeth
that's for sure
[Applause]
of course i didn't set myself up for
failure on this one
aaron please relax i'm trapped
and you're putting honey on me and
salmon
no they're not really doing that
that is terrifying
it's just psychological torture oh that
is messed up
i would do any stunt any physically
harmy
stunt over that thing with a bear any
day of the week you mean to tell
me that you would take the snake biting
your nose
yes wow i mean snakes are my biggest
fear but i recently conquered that fear
by holding a couple snakes for the first
time in my life only took 30 years
and now i love them now i love snakes
now i own snakes i have protrude sticks
now i bonnie with
all the time make love with snakes
surrounding me
bed of snakes every night you're
trapping alone with a bear
i could get out of control just maul you
to death yeah there's a lot that could
happen
in this few split seconds it takes to
get back in the room to figure out what
to do and so like it's it's funny it's
like that one clip is eclipsed the whole
rest of this
because you know they're going to save
their best cliff their most dangerous
one for last but yeah
it's usually some big high stakes like
we're shooting them out of a cannon into
space you know
some weird thing i wasn't expecting what
could be the equivalent of a horror
movie
i was just thinking like now i want the
next saw
just to be jack saw i was like just have
to have all of these guys
in a slot track because they probably
would have the best odds of escaping
you know what's weird the stakes feel
more raised because of how old
these guys are and it matters now like
you see johnny knoxville
uh i think it was stevo who said he's 49
here i'm like the dude looks like 68
years old
look how much stress this has put on his
body and i have to imagine that it's
this stuff that it's made of look as old
there are 49 year olds who do not look
at their age and he looks he looks like
20 years older than four yeah
yeah still is still sexy johnny
knoxville but yeah like
especially with the white hair and
everything i found myself throughout
this trailer being like oh god
you're too old like i've heard about the
reasons in the past they've had to like
stop shooting or that you've gone to the
hospital with an injury or
something and i know these movies are
hard to ensure you got to applaud their
dedication to this
but they are doing the passing of the
torch here from what i
read up on i believe that they are
they have some new people in here like i
think those were some of the people who
they were interviewing saying like i
grew up watching jackass
it is kind of fun to see that black
doodle stump performers who love jackass
and we're inspired from jackass are
actually getting
it's a little cooler than me than a
fictional movie that is
handing over the baton to like
characters i could care less about yeah
i'm like yeah
you can kind of give them a chance
because that's that's the unique thing
about jackass is that
as wacky and insane as it is as watching
people just behave like jackasses the
big part of it is they got to have
appealing personalities
yeah more than just being willing to do
the crazy stunts they gotta have
personalities that are
funny as hell daring in public and so
i'm really excited to see
who else they bring on board i'm nervous
about watching center people i know bam
marjara's not involved in this film
there's a whole
crazy you guys could read up on that
there's this whole thing where he was
supposed to be in it wasn't in it
it got into some legal battles some
restraining orders a whole
crazy thing that happened regarding it
personally bam margero was never my
favorite
so i don't really miss him well that's
the first thing is
it's like bam as i recall was always
like he's sexy and he's like kind of
funny in a rascally way but i always
feel like the the
dangerous stunts went to most of the
other people like they gave him like
uncomfortable things to do with things
that played on his own
phobias the skater boy had his own show
yeah absolutely but
but if you want to see some people get
hurt i feel like these are your guys and
then too i mean you could track like
that one guy's always doing something
with pooh
chris pontius is always getting his nuts
hit by something like
it's fascinating each member of the crew
has their own stunt that they do
yeah but of course you know this will be
the fourth film and the one that doesn't
have
ryan dunn in here may he rest in peace
and i feel like his presence
if anything if it'll be a missing
presence it would be ryan dunn who's
nicely felt and i hope they honor him in
here
and i wonder how they would do it
because you know it's got to be like
something heartfelt but
very irreverent yes yeah i'm very
excited for this
uh i'm nervous as hell but these are
some of the most
fun movies to watch i will never forget
sitting down that theater and the whole
shopping cart
hit and like feeling like wow they
really have transcended to the movies
and then
yeah feeling like somehow this works
it's somehow yeah this is
uh is such a big part of growing up
anyway guys
are you excited for jackass forever are
you worried for them leave your thoughts
down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button and last but not
least
rosa parra the biggest jackass of them
jackass oh dude you love crazy stunts
man i'm surprised you still have custody
of your own children with the kind of
daredevil or things you are
yeah always going into public stores
using the display toilets
you sick of it yeah yeah you disgusting
perfect yeah dressing up like an old
woman and do an uncomfortable improv
around
civilians or like jumping off of stuff
here's the issue rosa you're the last
patron of the dish
and it just so happened to be this video
wait we're always like we need a good
video to plug like roses you know social
media how great she's doing
and uh film twitter and actually just
her own film review blogs and everything
how how how much he's been blossoming
but unfortunately you landed on jackets
that's how we're talking about today and
you are the first she's so much not a
jackass and we used to do google
hangouts she couldn't keep up with the
jackass behavior
that she had to stop coming out so we
shifted to a more
you know personable vibe so
rosa thank you for being you and thank
you for being part of our patreon page
for
god knows how long at this point you
rock i'm sure i could look it up
but thank you